This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好，我是杰玛·斯佩克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们讨论
through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today we are talking about beauty. We're talking about attraction. Not in the way you may think. Mainly, we are talking about the theory that your thoughts contribute as deeply to your appearance as objective physical features and characteristics. Is that true? Do your thoughts change your attractiveness? and how exactly does that happen? How does loving ourselves actually have a biological physical impact?
我们20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。今天我们谈论的是美。我们谈论的是吸引力。不是你可能想的那种方式。主要是，我们谈论的是这样一种理论：你的思想对你外貌的影响，与客观的身体特征和特性一样深远。这是真的吗？你的思想会改变你的吸引力吗？这到底是怎么发生的？爱自己如何真正产生生物学上的身体影响？
Can I begin in a slightly different way this week? I want to tell you guys about this quote, my favorite quote, ever, just ever, full stop. I feel like I share a lot of quotes on this podcast. This one like takes the cake. And I feel like it's the reason I wanted to do this episode, because I've been thinking about it so often over the years. And finally, I was like, there must be some science to this. It's from Roll Dahl.
这周我可以以一种稍微不同的方式开始吗？我想告诉你们这个引言，我最喜欢的引言，有史以来，就是这样，句号。我觉得我在这个播客里分享了很多引言。这一条简直是登峰造极。我觉得这就是我想做这一集的原因，因为多年来我经常想到它。最后，我想，这背后一定有一些科学依据。它来自罗尔德·达尔。
He wrote Charlie in the Chocolate Factory, BFG. This quote came from the Twits. A person who has good thoughts cannot ever be ugly because those thoughts will shine out of your face like sunbeams and you will always look beautiful. Since I was a kid, this quote has resonated with me. I was an ugly kid. Let's be real.
他写了《查理和巧克力工厂》、《圆梦巨人》。这句话出自《蠢特夫妇》。一个拥有美好思想的人永远不会变丑，因为那些思想会像阳光一样从你的脸上闪耀出来，你看起来永远都很美。从我小时候起，这句话就引起了我的共鸣。我小时候是个丑孩子。说实话。
I was an ugly kid. And as an adult, I started to realize, and as a teenager I was like, okay, cards that I was dealt, if I control my thoughts, I really can not just change my appearance to other people, but how I feel internally, and that will change how I act. There have been people that I have met who are objectively beautiful, who are stunning, who have all the structural features of a very attractive person, but they have had such nasty thoughts towards others and towards themselves and towards
我小时候是个丑孩子。作为一个成年人，我开始意识到，作为一个青少年，我想，好吧，既然我拿到了这手牌，如果我能控制我的思想，我真的不仅可以改变我在别人眼中的外貌，还可以改变我内心的感受，这将改变我的行为。我遇到过一些客观上很美的人，他们令人惊叹，拥有一个非常有吸引力的人的所有结构特征，但他们对自己、对他人以及对
the world, and you can almost see it reflected in their faces. Like, there is a cruelty that comes with thinking mean things about other people. In contrast, some of the most beautiful people I've ever met, they will probably, maybe not ever model for like Prada or Vogue. You know, they may not be on the cover of magazines, but there is this kindness that shines out of them that means people are instantly attracted to them. People are drawn to them like a magnet. Why does this happen? Because I think that we've all experienced this. Somebody who is objectively beautiful, we are kind of like, we feel weird about, but somebody who is like, maybe not that, has that draw. Today we are going to investigate that phenomena and the deep scientific evidence
世界有着如此恶毒的想法，你几乎可以在他们的脸上看到这种反映。就像，对他人产生刻薄的想法会带来一种残忍。相比之下，我遇到过一些最美丽的人，他们可能永远不会为普拉达或Vogue做模特。你知道，他们可能不会出现在杂志封面上，但他们身上散发出一种善良，这意味着人们会被他们瞬间吸引。人们像磁铁一样被他们吸引。为什么会这样？因为我认为我们都经历过这种情况。对于一个客观上很美的人，我们感觉有点奇怪，但对于一个可能不是那样的人，却有那种吸引力。今天我们将调查这种现象以及深层的科学证据
as to how our thoughts shape the reality of our physicality and why focusing on self-love and kindness will make you an enigmatic person. It will pull people in in any room. So without further ado, let's talk about how loving yourself will scientifically, physically, psychologically, make you more attractive. All right, let's leave no mystery to even, to even begin here. Let's just jump straight into it. Yes, it is true. The way you think will have a significant impact on your physical appearance, there is
关于我们的思想如何塑造我们身体的现实，以及为什么专注于自爱和善良会让你成为一个神秘的人。它会吸引房间里的任何人。所以事不宜迟，让我们谈谈爱自己将如何在科学、身体和心理上让你更具吸引力。好吧，让我们不要留下任何悬念，甚至在开始时就直接进入主题。是的，这是真的。你的思维方式会对你的外貌产生重大影响，有
evidence of this, and I'm going to, I just have to give you guys that conclusion, the answer to the question before the explanation. It's true, physical beauty isn't everything. Your thoughts and your mentality have a much larger slice of the pie than you may think. Aaliyah Crum, she is a psychology professor, director of the Stanford Mind and Body Lab. She has conducted extensive research on something that we call the Mind Body Link. The Mind Body Link is this bidirectional, intimate communication between mental states, between our thoughts, emotions, beliefs, and our physical health and our physical form and reality.
证据表明这一点，我必须在解释之前先给你们这个结论，即问题的答案。这是真的，外在美并不是一切。你的思想和心态所占的比例比你想象的要大得多。阿莉亚·克拉姆，她是心理学教授，斯坦福身心实验室主任。她对我们称之为“身心联系”的东西进行了广泛的研究。身心联系是心理状态、我们的思想、情绪、信念与我们的身体健康、身体形态和现实之间这种双向的、亲密的交流。
She basically says our minds are not passive. observers. They do not simply perceive our reality as it is. Our minds change our reality, even on a biological level. There are so many instances where our mental beliefs affect our physical appearance, or just not just our appearance, but our physical reality. For example, there was an NYU study published this year, like two months ago in February, that talks about how women who are scared of aging, of becoming less attractive, of their physical health declining, actually age faster biologically when holding all else stable. These researchers, they basically concluded these women, their thoughts about the state of their
她基本上说我们的思想不是被动的观察者。它们不仅仅是感知我们现实本来的样子。我们的思想改变了我们的现实，甚至是在生物学层面上。有很多例子表明我们的心理信念会影响我们的外貌，或者不仅仅是我们的外貌，而是我们的身体现实。例如，今年，也就是两个月前的二月，发表了一项纽约大学的研究，谈到那些害怕衰老、害怕变得不再有吸引力、害怕身体健康下降的女性，在保持其他条件不变的情况下，实际上在生物学上衰老得更快。这些研究人员基本上得出结论，这些女性对她们身体状态的想法
body were powerful enough to influence the actual biological age of their body. This also applies to attractiveness. The more positively you feel about yourself, the more powerfully people perceive you. and of course we have heaps of evidence for this as well, how you think about your level of attractiveness. It influences, yes, firstly how you present and your confidence levels, which have a emotional impact, but there's evidence that it also impacts you on a more cellular level. Here is exactly how. Both our skin tissues and nervous system originate from the ectoderm, the outermost layer of cells on our body that go on to form our nervous system, our skin, our hair,
强大到足以影响她们身体的实际生物学年龄。这也适用于吸引力。你对自己感觉越积极，人们感知你的力量就越强大。当然，我们也有大量的证据证明这一点，即你如何看待自己的吸引力水平。它确实会影响，首先是你如何展示自己以及你的自信水平，这会产生情感影响，但有证据表明它也会在更细胞的层面上影响你。具体如下。我们的皮肤组织和神经系统都起源于外胚层，这是我们身体最外层的细胞层，它形成了我们的神经系统、皮肤、头发、
our nails, our sensory organs. The skin and the brain communicate through a network known as the skin brain axis. A simple, like very easy way of thinking about how our thoughts can influence our bodies is to consider this access and is to consider how chronic stress, chronic negative thoughts, chronic hatred about ourselves, heighten our stress response, heighten our nervous system response, heighten our central nervous system response, therefore disturbing all these other communications to the ectoderm, to our skin cells, to our organs. Many studies have shown that while short-term stress is important for survival, chronic stress, such as the stress that comes from hating yourself, the stress that comes from putting
指甲和感觉器官。皮肤和大脑通过一个被称为“皮肤-大脑轴”的网络进行交流。思考我们的思想如何影响我们身体的一种简单、非常容易的方法是考虑这个轴，并考虑慢性压力、长期的负面想法、对自己长期的仇恨如何加剧我们的压力反应，加剧我们的神经系统反应，加剧我们的中枢神经系统反应，从而扰乱所有这些对其他外胚层、皮肤细胞、器官的交流。许多研究表明，虽然短期压力对生存很重要，但慢性压力，例如源于自我厌恶的压力，源于贬低
yourself down can trigger a whole wide spectrum of just so many things that, again, I hate to say like attractive, unattractive, but that maybe aren't as healthy as our body could feel like and could look like. And it just goes to show the disturbances that self-hating thoughts can have on our appearance. Likewise, you know, feelings of shame as well, feelings of anger towards ourselves, feelings of anxiety can also literally cause inflammation and can compromise your immunity in ways that show up physically. I should say there is such a focus online at the moment. I'm sure you guys have noticed this. Such a focus on like inflammation being this terrible bad thing. Like I'm so inflamed. I have so much inflammation. If nobody has told you this, inflammation is actually,
自己的压力，可以触发一整套广泛的、再次，我讨厌说像有吸引力、没吸引力，但可能不像我们的身体感觉和看起来那样健康的东西。这恰恰表明了自我厌恶的想法对我们外貌的干扰。同样，你知道，羞耻感、对自己愤怒的感觉、焦虑的感觉也可能确实导致炎症，并以在身体上表现出来的方式损害你的免疫力。我应该说，目前网上有这样的关注。我相信你们已经注意到了。如此关注炎症是一件可怕的坏事。就像“我发炎得太厉害了”。“我有太多的炎症”。如果没人告诉过你，炎症实际上，
like some inflammation is good for you. It's a really good sign that your body is basically taking care of business. So you don't want to reduce all inflammation. But, you know, prolonged stress, anger, anxiety towards your, like anxiety about your life, about your appearance, environmental stresses, pain, amongst so many other things, can cause acute or chronic inflammation, which is brutal for so many reasons. It can affect body composition, skin, hair, which is important when we're talking about attraction. It also impacts mood and personality and health, which is much more important on a deeper level. If we work towards loving ourselves, if we work towards speaking kindly to ourselves, we give our brains and our nervous system
有些炎症对你有好处。这是一个非常好的迹象，表明你的身体基本上在处理事务。所以你不想减少所有的炎症。但是，你知道，长期的压力、愤怒、对你的生活、对你的外貌的焦虑、环境压力、疼痛，以及许多其他事情，会导致急性或慢性炎症，这在很多方面都是残酷的。它会影响身体成分、皮肤、头发，这在我们谈论吸引力时很重要。它还会影响情绪、个性和健康，这在更深层次上更重要。如果我们努力爱自己，如果我们努力善待自己，我们就会给大脑和神经系统
the best chance at keeping us healthy and that health is converted into physical attractiveness. It's so interesting to me that these days there's like so many quick fixes for like beauty. Like everywhere you go, there are like advertisements for Botox, Lit filler, surgery. And that seems to be like the first avenue that some people target when you should be targeting this baseline first of like, how do I think about myself? Do I love myself? Do I care about myself? Some people may say, this is just a placebo effect. It's not your thoughts that are changing your actual appearance. It's that your thoughts are changing your behaviors. It doesn't really matter. Whatever the mechanism, like the effect is obvious, especially when it comes to how others view us,
最好的机会来保持我们的健康，而这种健康会转化为身体吸引力。对我来说，这些天有这么多关于美的快速修复方法非常有趣。无论你走到哪里，都有肉毒杆菌、填充剂、手术的广告。当有些人应该首先针对这个基线时，这似乎是他们瞄准的第一条途径，即：我如何看待自己？我爱自己吗？我关心自己吗？有些人可能会说，这只是安慰剂效应。不是你的思想在改变你的实际外貌。而是你的思想在改变你的行为。这真的没关系。无论机制如何，效果都是显而易见的，特别是在别人如何看待我们方面，
which feels so shallow, but again, that's what the episode is about. There have been some really interesting theories recently, which say confidence specifically dominates objective attractiveness when it comes to other people's assessments of beauty. Let's look into that for a second. Let's look at the evidence. Studies show that those who view themselves as attractive have higher romantic self-confidence and self-esteem, which therefore influences how they behave in social and dating situations. And it really doesn't matter how objectively attractive they actually are. The subjective assessment of their attractiveness is what influences this above everything else. Having that kind of attractiveness changes everything from our body language to our ability or willingness to initiate
这感觉很肤浅，但同样，这就是这一集的主题。最近有一些非常有趣的理论，它们说在别人对美的评估方面，自信特别主导了客观的吸引力。让我们深入研究一下。让我们看看证据。研究表明，那些认为自己有吸引力的人拥有更高的浪漫自信和自尊，这反过来影响了他们在社交和约会情况下的行为。而他们客观上到底有多大的吸引力真的不重要。他们对自己吸引力的主观评估是影响这一点高于一切的因素。拥有那种吸引力会改变一切，从我们的肢体语言到我们发起
conversation, to our openness to strangers, which can make someone appear more open and reliable and trustworthy because they are receptive because they have this magnetic energy that says, talk to me. Like, let's come and interact with me. This is called social contagion. It is a rapid, often unconscious spread of emotions, behaviors, beliefs through a group of people, through a social network, because of mirror neurons, because of behavior mimicking and emotional contagion as well on top of social contagion. It explains, we've talked about this recently actually when it comes to trends. It explains how transform, why panic-driven behaviors happen, and it explains explains social perception and how your perception of yourself can travel to the people around you.
对话的能力或意愿，再到我们对陌生人的开放程度，这可以使一个人看起来更开放、更可靠、更值得信赖，因为他们是接受的，因为他们有这种磁性能量，说：“跟我说话。”就像，“来和我互动吧。”这被称为社会传染。它是情绪、行为、信念通过一群人、通过社交网络的一种快速的、通常是无意识的传播，因为镜像神经元，因为行为模仿，以及除了社会传染之外的情绪传染。它解释了，我们最近实际上谈到了这一点，当谈到趋势时。它解释了为什么恐慌驱动的行为会发生，它解释了社会感知，以及你对自己的感知如何传播给你周围的人。
This process, it's driven by automatic, built-in cognitive mechanisms rather than by conscious thought, but we can subconsciously influence that. We can subconsciously reprogram how we feel about ourselves through the repetition of positive self-affirmation, through the repetition of practices that prioritized self-love. That feeds into confidence, that confidence is what impacts other people's assessment of us. One particularly famous study about this asked to like 300 young adult, 300 around that young adults to rate their self-perceived attractiveness as well as self-reported confidence in their appearance, romantic relationships, and body esteem. The study found a strong correlation between having high self-perceived attractive,
这个过程是由自动的、内置的认知机制驱动的，而不是由有意识的思想驱动的，但我们可以潜意识地影响它。我们可以通过重复积极的自我肯定，通过重复优先考虑自爱的练习，潜意识地重新编程我们对自己的感觉。这会转化为自信，而那种自信正是影响他人对我们评估的因素。一项关于此的特别著名的研究要求大约300名年轻人评价他们自我感知的吸引力，以及自我报告的对他们外貌、浪漫关系和身体自尊的自信。该研究发现，拥有高自我感知吸引力，
again, regardless of actual attractiveness, high body esteem, high self-confidence, with overall self-esteem and with overall romantic attraction to those people. It's just, it's this weird thing. People like confident people because it's easy to be confident around them. And it's easy to buy into what somebody's trying to sell you about themselves when they really, believe it. A study from 1981 found that this may actually come down to, not just that, but down to emotional expressiveness. So people who display, as well, who are confident, display a lot of nonverbal cues for emotion, they're really able to infect the emotions and the mood of other people's in the room without saying anything, regardless of objective
同样，无论实际吸引力如何，高身体自尊、高自信，与整体自尊和对那些人的整体浪漫吸引力之间存在很强的相关性。这只是，这是一种奇怪的事情。人们喜欢自信的人，因为在他们身边很容易感到自信。当某人真正相信自己时，很容易相信他们试图向你推销的关于他们自己的东西。1981年的一项研究发现，这实际上可能归结为，不仅是那样，还归结为情感表达。所以那些表现出，同样，自信的人，表现出很多非语言的情绪线索，他们真的能够感染房间里其他人的情绪和心情，而无需说任何话，无论客观
attractiveness. They're also able to appear more friendly, more likable. I think what we need to understand again, I've kind of briefly explained this mechanism, but why? Like, why is it so infectious? Why is confidence like the superpower? I'm going to take a short break and then I'm going to lay it all out for you guys. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the
吸引力如何。他们也能够显得更友好、更讨人喜欢。我想我们需要再次理解，我已经简要解释了这个机制，但为什么？就像，为什么它如此具有传染性？为什么自信是超能力？我将休息一下，然后我会为你们揭晓这一切。所以请留下来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，以看透那些在健康行业中占主导地位的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap
我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击
Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代的快克。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在谈论。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you here on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way.
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同程度的信任。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你免费的Our Heart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini.
欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们，先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never. Mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要。招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Okay, so again, how we think about ourselves impacts how people see us,
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。请在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。好吧，所以再次强调，我们如何看待自己会影响别人如何看待我们，
that much we know why. I've given some explanations about like openness and about like people who feel good about themselves, make others feel good. But part and the biggest part, and the biggest part of the science behind why confidence is so infectious and why it makes people like us is that many of us seek out traits in a partner or in a friend that are difficult to observe directly. You know, we want somebody who was kind, who is competent, driven, liked by others and so on. And just meeting them for the first time or even a second time, like we have to make guesses. But someone being very confident when we meet them, that's a quality that we can measure. Like we can quickly be like, oh yeah, this person likes themselves.
我们知道为什么。我已经给出了一些关于开放性以及关于那些对自己感觉良好的人让别人感觉良好的解释。但部分，也是最大的一部分，也是自信之所以如此具有传染性以及为什么它让人们喜欢我们的科学背后的最大部分是，我们许多人在伴侣或朋友身上寻找那些难以直接观察到的特质。你知道，我们想要一个善良、能干、有动力、受他人喜爱等等的人。而第一次甚至第二次见到他们，我们必须进行猜测。但当我们在见到某人时，他们非常自信，那是一个我们可以衡量的品质。就像我们可以很快地说，哦，是的，这个人喜欢他们自己。
and that acts as an indication of all these other worthy traits because part of us trusts that people know themselves well, or at least they know themselves better than us. Therefore, we subconsciously assume that their confidence or their lack thereof reflects their value as a partner or a friend based on an accurate self-assessment. Whether that is true or not, it's something that we believe. To test this again, there was another study in 2015. It looked at how people, like, you know, viewed and perceived potential romantic partners who were overconfident in themselves and who had a bit too much to say about themselves, were they going to be put off by that arrogance? In this study, they specifically focused on a group of people who claimed to have knowledge
这充当了所有这些其他值得拥有的特质的指示，因为我们的一部分相信人们很了解自己，或者至少他们比我们更了解自己。因此，我们潜意识地假设他们的自信或缺乏自信反映了他们作为伴侣或朋友的价值，基于准确的自我评估。无论这是真的还是假的，这是我们相信的东西。为了再次测试这一点，2015年进行了另一项研究。它观察了人们如何看待和感知那些对自己过度自信、对自己说得太多、会被那种傲慢所推开的潜在浪漫伴侣。在这项研究中，他们专门关注了一群声称拥有
of information that simply didn't exist. People who were cocky, basically. The study had the overconfident people write up dating apps. and then they had a separate group of people, all opposite sex participants, read those dating profiles and rate the authors. Basically, do you think this person would be attractive? The overconfident group, even though they didn't have pictures of them, even though they didn't have any visual indicators, a lot of these people were like, yeah, I think that this person
根本不存在的信息知识的人。基本上就是那些自大的人。该研究让过度自信的人写了约会应用程序。然后他们让另一组人，所有异性参与者，阅读那些约会资料并评价作者。基本上，你认为这个人会有吸引力吗？过度自信的那一组，即使他们没有他们的照片，即使他们没有任何视觉指标，很多人还是说，是的，我认为这个人
would be attractive. I think that this person would be, yeah, would be beautiful because of how it impacted their perceptions. Why would somebody, you know, behave this way? They weren't beautiful. You know, why would they have all this confidence if they didn't have something to back it up? That's basically the formula or basically the mechanism that some researchers and psychologists used to explain why confidence is so alluring. Basically, because a confidence is a mental shortcut for assessing how well somebody knows themselves and believing that somebody knows that they are a good person and that they are an attractive person, they are a kind person, because otherwise, why would they feel this way? Obviously, it kind of doesn't account for arrogance,
会有吸引力。我认为这个人会是，是的，会很美，因为这影响了他们的感知。为什么有人会，你知道，表现得这样？他们并不美。你知道，如果他们没有一些东西来支持它，他们为什么会有这么多自信？这基本上是某些研究人员和心理学家用来解释为什么自信如此诱人的公式或机制。基本上，因为自信是评估一个人对自己了解程度的心理捷径，并相信某人知道他们是一个好人，他们是一个有吸引力的人，他们是一个善良的人，因为否则，他们为什么会有这种感觉？显然，它有点没有考虑到傲慢，
which is why sometimes, you know, we'll find somebody really attractive until we realize, oh wait, you really think that you're amazing. But in terms of first impressions, it is very, very powerful. We can go even further with this and talk about how, talk about mirror neurons and talk about facial expressions and how basically as well, confidence is one thing. Having positive thoughts, loving yourself means that you are better able to be conscious of what other people are doing around you because you are not so critical of yourself. Essentially, you're better able to reciprocate other people's behavior because you're not self-conscious. A University of Wisconsin study showed that people simulate the facial expressions of people around them, and in that, that creates
这就是为什么有时，你知道，我们会发现某人非常有吸引力，直到我们意识到，哦等等，你真的认为你很了不起。但在第一印象方面，它非常、非常强大。我们可以更进一步，谈谈镜像神经元，谈谈面部表情，以及基本上，自信是一回事。拥有积极的想法，爱自己意味着你能够更好地意识到周围的人在做什么，因为你对自己没有那么挑剔。本质上，你能够更好地回报他人的行为，因为你没有自我意识。威斯康星大学的一项研究表明，人们模拟周围人的面部表情，而在那之中，这创造了
emotional responsiveness in those people. Essentially, if you are less in your head, more in the present, you are more likely to reciprocate how other people are acting, and that creates a ripple effect of positive emotion in those around you, or if you're the one who originated the smile as well. It signals responsiveness. It signals that you are approachable and that you are ultimately attractive because you've opened this emotional door for other people to enter. Basically, there is a connection there that says, I'm engaged, I believe in myself, I believe in you. That makes people like you. Basically, to do a mini summary of all this because I feel like I'm going in circles. We like people who know themselves. We like people who think of themselves as worthwhile.
那些人的情感反应。本质上，如果你少想自己，多活在当下，你就更有可能回报他人的行为，这会在周围的人中产生积极情绪的涟漪效应，或者如果你也是那个发起微笑的人。它发出了响应的信号。它发出了你平易近人，并且你最终是有吸引力的信号，因为你为其他人打开了这扇情感之门。基本上，那里有一种联系，说：我参与其中，我相信自己，我相信你。这让人们喜欢你。基本上，为了对所有这些做一个小总结，因为我觉得我在绕圈子。我们喜欢了解自己的人。我们喜欢认为自己有价值的人。
We like those who are emotionally and socially reciprocal. All of those things we can change regardless of actual physical appearance, because it comes down to charisma, to getting out of our own head and to emotional intelligence. That is really the power here. Being present, being confident, being calm. So how does this compare to making physical changes to your appearance? don't get me wrong, this mental reprogramming of like, I am beautiful, I am worthy, I am hot, I look great. It takes time, like it takes a lot of time. And some people may prefer to just fix the insecurity that's really standing in their way. Like, normally they can be like, I feel really great about everything else, but, you know, I don't really like my nose, I don't really like my boobs,
我们喜欢那些在情感和社交上互惠的人。所有这些事情我们都可以改变，无论实际的外貌如何，因为它归结为魅力，归结为走出自己的头脑，归结为情商。这才是真正的力量所在。活在当下，自信，冷静。那么这与对外貌进行身体改变相比如何？别误会我的意思，这种“我很美，我很值得，我很性感，我看起来很棒”的心理重编程。这需要时间，就像它需要很多时间。有些人可能更喜欢直接修复真正阻碍他们的不安全感。就像，通常他们可以觉得，我对其他一切都感觉很好，但是，你知道，我不喜欢我的鼻子，我不喜欢我的胸部，
I don't really like my cheeks, they can get those surgeries, do interventions like that that remove the initial insecurity work long term. I'm not saying do they make, make somebody more attractive because they probably do it. It's something that they really want, and I'm not here to tell you what you can and can't do with your body. There's enough of that in the world. You really can do whatever you want, and I will support everybody's decision. But what I do think is important is, like, when we are talking about the secret source to confidence and the secret source to being attractive, is it all physical, does surgery remove the internal insecurity? there was a study in Nye of like 1,500 girls over, and women, I guess, because it was over a 13-year period,
我不喜欢我的脸颊，他们可以去做那些手术，做那样的干预，消除最初的不安全感，长期有效。我不是说他们让某人更有吸引力，因为他们可能确实做到了。这是他们真正想要的，我不是来告诉你可以或不可以对你的身体做什么。世界上已经有足够多的那种声音了。你真的可以做任何你想做的事，我会支持每个人的决定。但我认为重要的是，当我们谈论自信的秘诀和有吸引力的秘诀时，它是完全身体上的吗？手术能消除内在的不安全感吗？在纽约有一项研究，对1500名女孩进行了超过13年的跟踪，
and it measured appearance satisfaction, mental health, all that kind of thing, at different points, and then also how many of these girls and then women got surgery? So basically, time one, they were children, they were like, how insecure are you, time two, how insecure are you and have you gotten surgery? Five percent of them reported having cosmetic surgery at some point between those years. What's interesting is that those who reported high levels of depression and anxiety and insecurity were more likely to get cosmetic surgery in the first place. Afterwards though, their levels of anxiety, their levels of depression,
女性，我想，因为那是超过13年的时间，它测量了外貌满意度、心理健康，所有那种事情，在不同的时间点，还有多少这些女孩和后来的女性做了手术？所以基本上，时间一，她们是孩子，她们是，你有多不安全，时间二，你有多不安全，你做过手术吗？其中5%的人报告在这些年间的某个时候做过整容手术。有趣的是，那些报告有高水平抑郁、焦虑和不安全感的人，更有可能首先去做整容手术。然而之后，她们的焦虑水平、抑郁水平，
especially around how they looked, did not decrease. It did not go away. Having cosmetic surgery didn't help alleviate the emotional wounds for them that, for a lot of them they said had caused this pain, being bullied, being criticized by parents. Now, not all of them did this out of insecurity. I'm not saying that. But if we are driven to surgery to fix insecurity and fix anxiety, it doesn't seem to be the fix that we think it is. Another study followed 98 women and two men for two years across the US. And these patients answered questions about their satisfaction, like body satisfaction, body image, self-esteem, symptoms of depression as well
特别是关于她们看起来如何的，并没有减少。它没有消失。做整容手术并没有帮助她们减轻情感创伤，对于她们中的许多人来说，她们说这导致了这种痛苦，被欺负，被父母批评。现在，并非所有人都出于不安全感这样做。我不是那个意思。但如果我们被驱动去做手术来修复不安全感和修复焦虑，它似乎并不是我们认为的那种修复方法。另一项研究在美国跟踪了98名女性和两名男性，为期两年。这些患者回答了关于她们满意度的问题，比如身体满意度、身体形象、自尊、抑郁症状，以及
before cosmetic surgery and then again afterwards, or between then and when they got the surgery and then a couple years later. Each subject during the time of the study had at least one, five, very popular procedures, so breast augmentation, rhinoplasties, BPLs, that sort of thing. the patients reported being satisfied with the outcome of their plastic surgery. They didn't report any increase in happiness, though. Whatsoever. For those who did, it was very minor. It was a temporary boost.
在整容手术之前，然后再次之后，或者在那之间以及当她们做手术时，然后几年后。研究期间的每个受试者至少做过一次、五次非常受欢迎的手术，比如隆胸、隆鼻、BPL，那种事情。患者报告对整形手术的结果感到满意。然而，她们并没有报告任何幸福感的增加。一点也没有。对于那些确实有的人，那是非常轻微的。那是一个暂时的提升。
Basically, I think these studies are asking us to consider our desires for cosmetic procedures and ask ourselves, if it's confidence and attractiveness I'm after, will this actually solve my problem if I don't work on my internal sense of self-love? Or will my mind just keep it? searching for what's wrong next. Again, I'm going to say this. There's no judgment in this. I've considered chisemitic procedures myself. I will probably get one at some stage. Maybe I can't say, but I probably think I will. If my friends have cosmetic surgeries, I think they look fantastic and I think it was the right decision for them. It's just about
基本上，我认为这些研究要求我们考虑我们对整容手术的渴望，并问自己，如果我追求的是自信和吸引力，如果我不致力于内在的自爱感，这真的能解决我的问题吗？还是我的大脑会继续？寻找下一个错误。再次，我要说这一点。这没有评判。我自己也考虑过整容手术。我可能在某个阶段会做一个。也许我不能说，但我可能认为我会。如果我的朋友做了整容手术，我认为她们看起来棒极了，我认为这对她们来说是正确的决定。这只是关于
addressing the root cause. Because in contrast, a study that looked at over 700 patients with body dysmorphia, who were treated with cognitive behavioral therapy, found that every single one of them responded well to that treatment and every single one of them had an improved quality of life, felt better about themselves, felt long lasting changes, not just to their well being, but to things like their confidence levels as well. That was the comparison. Surgery versus doing the deep inner work, maybe doing both at the same time would be ridiculously powerful. What these studies are really saying is that there are a few layers to attractiveness. Just to summarize, there is an internal layer, there is an external layer. Being attractive is not just about performing
解决根本原因。因为相比之下，一项观察了700多名患有身体畸形恐惧症的患者的研究，他们接受了认知行为疗法，发现他们中的每一个人都对那种治疗反应良好，并且他们中的每一个人都改善了生活质量，对自己感觉更好，感受到了持久的变化，不仅是对他们的幸福感，而且对像自信水平这样的事情也是如此。这就是比较。手术与做深层的内在工作，也许同时做这两件事会非常强大。这些研究真正要说的是，吸引力有几个层面。总结一下，有一个内在层面，有一个外在层面。有吸引力不仅仅是关于表现。
for others or fitting within a very narrow idea of what beautiful looks like. It is also about self-acceptance. That final ingredient, you can do everything you want to your body, that final ingredient brings a magnetism that is deeply powerful and cannot be replicated. And yes, like surgeries, makeup, clothes, like contribute to that. But you also also, you also, have to rewire the ways that society has taught you to hate yourself. That is a superpower. When you realize like hating myself has never made my life better, has never got me out of a problem, has never made me more attractive and has never attracted the love I want to me, it is a magic spell. That's what my aunt used to always say. Like put on your magic spell,
或是为了迎合某种狭隘的审美标准。这同样关乎自我接纳。那最后的一味配方——你可以对自己的身体做任何你想做的事——那最后的一味配方能带来一种深沉而强大的磁场，这是无法复制的。是的，像手术、化妆、穿搭，这些确实有帮助。但你还必须、必须、必须重塑那些社会教导你用来厌恶自己的方式。那是一种超能力。当你意识到“厌恶自己从未让我的生活变得更好，从未帮我解决过问题，从未让我变得更有魅力，也从未吸引到我想要的爱”时，这就像一道魔法咒语。我姑姑以前总是这么说。她说，给自己施个魔法咒语吧，
like put on your self-love spell. If you cast that on yourself, it's intoxicating. When people see somebody that is truly in love with themselves and thinks they're great, that person is the most beautiful person you've ever met. Think about it. Like, what's the most beautiful person you've ever seen? Sure, they were beautiful. There was something else though, wasn't there? Like, you remember the feeling of being around them. You remember the feeling of like, seeing how they walked, seeing how they spoke, seeing how they acted. Like, that was the ingredient that really, like, made the pie. With that in mind, let's get to the advice giving part of this episode. Let's talk about four ways to rewire your self-perception and therefore your
给自己施个自爱咒语吧。如果你对自己施下这个咒语，那会让人沉醉。当人们看到一个真正爱自己、认为自己很棒的人时，那个人就是你见过的最美的人。想一想。你见过的最美的人是谁？当然，他们外表很美。但还有别的东西，不是吗？你记得和他们在一起时的那种感觉。你记得看到他们走路的样子、说话的样子、行事的样子时的那种感觉。那才是真正让这道“派”变得完美的配方。带着这个想法，让我们进入本期节目的建议环节。让我们谈谈重塑自我认知，进而重塑你的
physical appearance, your beauty, using your thoughts. First up, and this is one of the most powerful mechanisms for so many things, develop a visualization ritual that transports you into a confident state by conjuring like an internal vision of how you want to be perceived. Make it magical, make it wonderful. I'm going to give you some examples. This is going to explain this better. The best one out there is the golden orb exercise. I've spoken about this before, but if you want to feel more confident, imagine a golden, bright orb sitting right in your heart, emanating from your chest, and with each breath, it goes a few inches wider, a few inches wider, until it starts to engulf people, bring people into the fold, make them feel just pulled towards
外在形象和美的四种方法，利用你的思想。首先，这是许多事情中最强大的机制之一，建立一个可视化仪式，通过构想你想要被如何看待的内在愿景，将你带入一种自信的状态。让它变得神奇，让它变得美妙。我会给你举几个例子，这样能解释得更清楚。目前最好的方法是“金球练习”。我之前提到过，但如果你想感觉更自信，想象一个明亮的金球就在你的心脏位置，从你的胸口散发出来，随着每一次呼吸，它向外扩大几英寸，再扩大几英寸，直到它开始包围周围的人，把人们带入你的磁场，让他们感到被你吸引。
you. Some people also think about it like a force field as like a magnet, like this is your secret armor, that mental visualization of like, I'm going to project my mind outwards to bring people inwards. That brings a glow. That makes people attracted to you because of how you are thinking about yourself in the context of them. These visualization rituals leverage something that we call embodied cognition. So when you imagine, when you visualize energy radiating from your body or protecting you like an armor, your brain treats that. as the truth that filters into your conscious thoughts, that filters into your deliberate behavior, meaning you shift your posture, meaning you shift your breathing, meaning that your attention
有些人也把它想象成一个力场，像磁铁一样，这是你的秘密盔甲。那种“我要向外投射我的思想以吸引人们向内”的心理可视化，会带来一种光芒。这让人们因为你对自己的看法以及你与他们的关系而对你产生吸引力。这些可视化仪式利用了我们所说的“具身认知”。所以，当你想象、当你可视化能量从你的身体辐射出来，或者像盔甲一样保护你时，你的大脑会将其视为真相，这会渗透到你的意识思维中，渗透到你的刻意行为中，这意味着你改变了姿态，改变了呼吸，意味着你的注意力
really begins to be more finely tuned, meaning you pay attention to things about yourself that you like. It also just on a physical level, like changes muscle tension, changes heart rate, this all feeds back into the emotional experience of making you feel more powerful, therefore changing how you physically present as powerful and confident. Another thing I've done in the past is that before I've walked into a date, before I've walked into a room, a meeting, a party, I give myself three compliments. I am smart. I have great hair.
开始变得更加敏锐，意味着你开始关注自己身上那些你喜欢的特质。在生理层面，它也会改变肌肉紧张度，改变心率，这一切都会反馈到情感体验中，让你感到更强大，从而改变你呈现出的强大和自信的身体状态。我过去做过的另一件事是，在去约会、走进房间、开会或参加派对之前，我会给自己三个赞美。我很聪明。我的头发很棒。
I don't know. I have great eyes. Things like that. I force myself to give myself those compliments and then walk in. Because that's grounding. Like that is a very powerful form of cognitive priming. you enter a room now looking for evidence that people are responding to you in a positive way because you have primed your mind to be receiving of that. You have primed your mind to feel beautiful.
我不知道。我的眼睛很漂亮。诸如此类。我强迫自己给自己这些赞美，然后走进去。因为这能让你脚踏实地。这是一种非常强大的认知启动形式。你现在走进房间时，会寻找人们积极回应你的证据，因为你已经启动了你的大脑去接收这些。你已经启动了你的大脑去感受自己的美。
I generally find that just reminding myself of my positive qualities also becomes quite a self-fulfilling prophecy. I can go into a situation, reminded of my good sense of humor, reminded of my ability to listen, and it gives me a little mental nudge to be more present, to be like to be trusting of this unconscious or subconscious part of me that's going to take over and mean that I will be okay because in the past I've always been okay. And even if I haven't, I now have new skills. Next, it can be useful to turn your self-care routine into a kind of ritual or ceremony that's less on fixating about how the world thinks you look or how you present and more about spending time with yourself, having a quiet moment whilst you're doing a face mask, whilst you're brushing your teeth,
我通常发现，仅仅提醒自己拥有积极的品质，本身就会成为一种自我实现的预言。我可以带着对自己幽默感、倾听能力的提醒进入一个场合，这给了我一点心理暗示，让我更加专注，让我去信任我内心那部分无意识或潜意识，它会接管一切，意味着我会没事的，因为过去我一直都挺过来了。即使没有，我现在也有了新的技能。接下来，将你的自我护理程序变成一种仪式或典礼会很有用，不要太执着于世界认为你看起来如何或你如何呈现自己，而是更多地关于与自己共处，在敷面膜、刷牙时享受一段安静的时光，
whilst you're doing, brushing your hair, whatever. This is practices of self-love. With each movement, think of that action as a token of appreciation, as a form of love. Imagine you are brushing your hair. It's the hair of your childhood self. Imagine it's little you sitting in front of you and you're brushing your hair out of love. Imagine cooking a nourishing meal for the most gentlest parts of yourself. Making your bed nice and comfy or neat as a deep act of devotion to yourself.
在梳头时，无论做什么。这些都是自爱的练习。每一次动作，都把那个行为看作是一种欣赏的表示，一种爱的形式。想象你在梳头。那是你童年时期的头发。想象那是小小的你坐在你面前，你出于爱在为她梳头。想象为自己最温柔的部分烹饪一顿营养餐。把床铺得整整齐齐、舒适宜人，作为一种对自己的深情奉献。
You are worthy of being treated nicely. You are worthy of being adored. You are a creature of softness and beauty. Treat yourself as such. Literally act towards yourself with the most purest form of endearment and kindness and love and devotion and loyalty so that your brain begins to internalize we are worthy of this behavior. We are worthy of being treated this way because we are a beautiful, magical, wonderful person. Okay, I have a couple final tips. We're going to take one more short break before we get into them. Stay with us. 2%.
你值得被温柔对待。你值得被宠爱。你是一个充满柔情与美的生命。请这样对待自己。从字面上看，以最纯粹的爱慕、善良、爱、奉献和忠诚来对待自己，这样你的大脑就会开始内化：我们值得这种行为。我们值得被这样对待，因为我们是一个美丽、神奇、美妙的人。好了，我还有最后几个小贴士。在进入这些内容之前，我们再休息一小会儿。请留下来。2%。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
这是在有自动扶梯的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家交谈，深入探讨那些主导健康产业、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的吗？我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“2%”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。说清楚，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你补全那句话。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking,
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，当你活在世上时？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is served in Arizona.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。
And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
在这个新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Let's talk about the role of exercise in making you more attractive and not in the way you think, not in like the excessive cardio way, in the mental way.
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。让我们谈谈运动在让你更有魅力方面的作用，不是你想的那种方式，不是那种过度的有氧运动方式，而是心理层面的。
Exercise and movement make you more attractive because of the appreciation they create for our bodies and the neutrality and the gratitude we develop towards our physical form and what it is capable of. Instead of what it could do better and how it could look better and how it failed, us in in terms of beauty. If you cannot love your body, as it is, as you want it to be, at least respect it for what it allows you to see, enjoy, witness, move through. Movement and exercise connects you with that deeper appreciation that translates into good habits, translates into confidence, translates into health. This doesn't have to be exercise. This could be something you do with your hands, like pottery, something you do with your legs, hiking, carrying
运动和活动让你更有魅力，因为它们创造了对我们身体的欣赏，以及我们对身体形态及其能力所产生的客观和感激之情。而不是它本可以做得更好、看起来更好、或者在美感方面让我们失望。如果你不能爱你的身体，正如它现在的样子，正如你想要的样子，至少要尊重它，因为它让你看到、享受、见证、经历。运动和锻炼将你与那种更深层的欣赏联系起来，转化为良好的习惯，转化为自信，转化为健康。这不一定是运动。这可以是你可以用手做的事情，比如陶艺，用腿做的事情，徒步旅行，搬运
heavy grocery bags, climbing, life drawing, being a nude model, like something more embodied like dancing. Anything at all that challenges the idea that your body only exists to carry around your brain or to be looked at or to be critiqued is so important. And having a healthy relationship with movement as something that really fuels your soul, makes you feel alive, brings energy back into your body is incredibly biologically powerful as well as psychologically powerful. Even just connecting with your body on a sensory level, disconnecting from it is something that needs to be witnessed and something that needs to be experienced is just so powerful because you really, yeah, it's that gratitude thing,
沉重的杂货袋，攀岩，人体写生，做裸体模特，或者像跳舞这样更具具身性的活动。任何挑战“你的身体只存在于承载你的大脑、被观看或被批评”这一观念的事情都非常重要。拥有与运动的健康关系，将其视为真正滋养你的灵魂、让你感到活着、将能量带回你身体的东西，在生物学和心理学上都极其强大。即使只是在感官层面上与你的身体连接，从它身上断开连接，这是一种需要被见证和体验的东西，这非常强大，因为你真的，是的，这就是那种感激之情，
but you stop being in this mindset of feeling constantly monitored. And again, I think I've really nowed this a few times, now this home, but I'm going to do it a more time. Like, when you are obsessed with your physical appearance, when you are obsessed with how you look, you are immediately less attractive because you are distracted, right? You are distracted because you are constantly monitoring how other people are seeing you. You're not connecting with them. you're not making eye contact. You're not thinking or you're not interested or interesting. Like you are just internalized. You're shutting down into like really rapid and harsh self-assessment.
但你不再处于那种不断被监视的感觉中。再说一次，我想我已经强调过几次了，把这一点讲透了，但我还要再说一次。当你沉迷于你的外表，当你沉迷于你看起来如何时，你立刻就变得不那么有魅力了，因为你分心了，对吧？你分心了，因为你不断地在监视别人是如何看你的。你没有与他们连接。你没有眼神交流。你没有思考，或者你并不有趣。你只是内化了。你陷入了非常迅速和严厉的自我评估中。
In contrast, like genuinely being like my form is just the vessel through which I live my life. It is just how I do things and how I go about experiencing things. That is what builds attractiveness because you are able to be more present. and therefore more confident and more engaged with other people. Sorry to go on a rant with that, but finally, my final thing, instead of focusing on how to look, smacks, what needs to be tweaked, what needs to be changed, what weight needs to be gained or lost. Like, similar to what I just said, work on making yourself more interesting. More interesting to yourself, more interested in others.
相比之下，真正地认为“我的形态只是我生活其中的容器”。它只是我做事和体验事物的方式。这才是建立吸引力的原因，因为你能够更加专注。因此更加自信，与他人更加互动。抱歉对此长篇大论，但最后，我的最后一件事，不要专注于如何看起来很棒，什么需要调整，什么需要改变，什么体重需要增加或减少。就像我刚才说的，努力让自己变得更有趣。对自己更有趣，对他人更感兴趣。
This is the most alluring quality you can have. interesting people are fascinating and people who show a deep desire to know others and who make eye contact and you remember people's names and remember the trips they just went on and remember the fun facts that they told them who are interested in their stories those people have game like people want to be around people like that how many times have you met someone who you didn't immediately think was attractive then you like saw them talk about something they really cared about and all you saw them like make everybody laugh and you were like oh my god like hey okay like hello like that person is that person looks and feels good if you want to be more attractive have something
这是你能拥有的最迷人的品质。有趣的人令人着迷，那些表现出深入了解他人渴望的人，那些进行眼神交流、记住人们的名字、记住他们刚去的旅行、记住他们告诉他们的趣事、对他们的故事感兴趣的人，那些人有魅力。人们想和那样的人在一起。你遇到过多少次这样的人，你起初并不觉得他们有吸引力，然后你看到他们谈论他们真正关心的事情，看到他们让每个人都大笑，你当时就想，天哪，嘿，好吧，你好，那个人看起来和感觉起来都很棒。如果你想更有魅力，有你关心的事情，
you care about have something you can rant about have a cause that you dedicate time to the most attractive thing somebody can be is interested and interesting like have the hobby have some have a deep dive have a Wikipedia page you know everything about. Like, it's a grounding part of your identity. What it really is is that people look at you and they're like, oh, they know themselves so well, they cannot be disturbed by anything I have to say. Like, that person isn't even worth trying to make feel bad. They know themselves. I also think, like, being a great conversationalist also comes into this as well. People we've seen love people who reciprocate. They also love people who make them feel seen. Like, it goes beyond
有你可以滔滔不绝的事情，有你投入时间的事业。一个人最吸引人的地方就是感兴趣和有趣。拥有爱好，深入研究，拥有一个你了解一切的维基百科页面。这是一种扎根的身份认同。真正的情况是，人们看着你，他们会想，哦，他们非常了解自己，他们不会被我说的任何话所干扰。那个人甚至不值得试图让他们感觉不好。他们了解自己。我也认为，成为一个伟大的谈话者也包含在这一点中。我们见过的人喜欢那些有回应的人。他们也喜欢那些让他们感到被看见的人。这超越了
confident. If you can't be confident, be intrigued, leave pauses in conversation. Remember that every great conversationalist you have met has learned that skill. It is a skill. It is a skill of nonverbal communication. It is a skill of appreciating silence. It is a skill of the two to one question ratio of never forgetting a name, never forgetting a detail. Concentrating on one person at a time. If you cannot be objectively attractive, be confident. If you cannot be confident, be a great conversationalist. There is a science to having great conversations. There's a system, I should say. And you can learn to embody that. You can learn to engage and talk to anybody in any single room. And that immediately, I think, makes you more beautiful and more of a pure, enlightened, fabulous person to be around.
自信。如果你不能自信，那就保持好奇，在谈话中留下停顿。记住，你遇到的每一位伟大的谈话者都学会了那项技能。这是一种技能。这是一种非语言交流的技能。这是一种欣赏沉默的技能。这是一种二比一的问题比例的技能，永远不要忘记名字，永远不要忘记细节。一次专注于一个人。如果你不能客观地有吸引力，那就自信。如果你不能自信，那就成为一个伟大的谈话者。进行伟大的谈话是有科学依据的。我应该说，有一个系统。你可以学会体现这一点。你可以学会与任何房间里的任何人互动和交谈。我认为这立刻让你变得更美，成为一个更纯粹、更开明、更棒的人。
Because you make people feel human and feel seen, which is all we ever really want. Finally, finally. I know I said finally, like six times now, but definitely finally. I just need you to remember, as much as we think that beauty is objective, there is a large, like a large part of it is subjective. Just because you look different from the current beauty standard, just because you will never have that nose, never have that physique, never have whatever that person has, those muscles, doesn't mean that, like, you are not a beautiful person.
因为你让人们感到人性化和被看见，这正是我们真正想要的。最后，最后。我知道我已经说了六次最后了，但这绝对是最后一次。我只需要你记住，尽管我们认为美是客观的，但很大一部分是主观的。仅仅因为你看起来与当前的审美标准不同，仅仅因为你永远不会有那个鼻子，永远不会有那种体格，永远不会有那个人拥有的东西，那些肌肉，并不意味着你不是一个美丽的人。
I really do think the world is moving towards uniqueness rather than like straight up and down cookie cutter beauty. Like that is the biggest asset you have, that you are a little bit different, that you are somebody who is enigmatic in that they know themselves. Like that is one of the longest lasting gifts you can give yourself. To love yourself so deeply that it becomes a feature of how people see you. And it becomes and it is represented. physically in like the sun that shines out of your face. It is represented physically in how your
我真的认为世界正在走向独特性，而不是那种千篇一律的刻板美。这是你拥有的最大资产，你有一点不同，你是一个因为了解自己而显得神秘的人。这是你能给自己的最持久的礼物之一。如此深爱自己，以至于它成为人们看待你的一个特征。它在身体上表现为从你脸上散发出的阳光。它在身体上表现为你的
skin feels, how your hair looks, how your nervous system is regulated. The more you tend to your inner life, the bigger the world around you becomes. And it's not just about romantic interest. It's not just about whether people find you attractive. It's about the spaces that you put yourself in. it's about the opportunities and luck that come your way. Again, we can worry as much, we can worry until the cows come home about whether that person finds us hot, about whether, you know, wherever we're going to be that size, look that way. And at the end of the day, it's important, but it really doesn't matter all that much. Because are you having fun? Are you enjoying yourself? Do you feel lucky to be alive? Do you really engage? Are you interested and interesting to other people?
皮肤感觉如何，头发看起来如何，神经系统调节得如何。你越关注你的内心生活，你周围的世界就变得越大。这不仅仅是关于浪漫的兴趣。这不仅仅是关于人们是否觉得你有吸引力。这是关于你置身其中的空间。这是关于你遇到的机会和运气。再说一次，我们可以担心，我们可以担心到天荒地老，关于那个人是否觉得我们性感，关于我们是否会达到那个尺寸，看起来那样。归根结底，这很重要，但它真的没那么重要。因为你玩得开心吗？你享受自己吗？你觉得活着很幸运吗？你真的投入了吗？你对别人感兴趣且有趣吗？
that's going to get you so much further than just having good looks. Honestly, if the evidence hasn't proven it enough, hopefully you get evidence through experience and you see how life-changing that is, like how life-changing it is to reprogram yourself out of self-hatred and into self-love. So thank you for listening to this episode. I know I went on a lot of little rants. I know that I covered so many things. So if you're still here, thank you for being a loyal.
这会让你比仅仅拥有好看的外表走得更远。老实说，如果证据还不够证明这一点，希望你能通过经验获得证据，看到它是多么改变生活，从自我厌恶中重塑自己，进入自爱是多么改变生活。所以感谢收听这一集。我知道我发了很多小牢骚。我知道我涵盖了太多事情。所以如果你还在听，感谢你成为一个忠实的
listener, leave a little emoji down below. What's our emoji going to be of the day? Oh, surely a golden orb, surely a little sun emoji, surely a little star emoji to represent our golden orb exercise. Make sure that you, if you are listening, have perhaps checked us out on Netflix. Yes, we are on Netflix now. We have so many episodes over there if you are in the mood to catch up on a little bit of video podcasting. You can also follow us on Instagram. Make sure you are following wherever you are listening right now so you get new episodes directly to your feed. You guys know the deal. It's all in the description. There's so many links down there at the stage that you could get lost. But yeah, go and check it out. And thank you as always to our researcher Lucy
听众，在下面留下一个小表情符号吧。我们今天的表情符号是什么？哦，肯定是一个金球，肯定是一个小太阳表情符号，肯定是一个小星星表情符号来代表我们的金球练习。如果你正在收听，请确保你可能已经在Netflix上查看过我们。是的，我们现在在Netflix上了。如果你有心情赶上一点视频播客，我们那里有很多集。你也可以在Instagram上关注我们。确保你在收听的地方关注我们，这样你就能直接在你的订阅源中获得新剧集。你们知道规矩。都在描述里。那个阶段下面有太多的链接，你可能会迷路。但是的，去看看吧。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员露西
Davidson for her help and contributions and research with this episode. Until next time, be safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts.
戴维森对这一集的帮助、贡献和研究。下次见，注意安全。善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再谈。2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“2%”。
On The Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it
在《Look Back at it》播客上。1979年，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, or wherever you get your podcasts.
和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人，基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.
它向世界发出信号，你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让双胞胎怀孕。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·拉尼尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着季节的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he did.
劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。
serves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me babe. On the iHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an iHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
服务。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。